today we're talking about sustainability
apogee pay as you go reducing costs with
containers and data governance
i'm ryan shaw and welcome to this week
in cloud where we serve you the lowest
latency news the google cloud ready
sustainability program has 12 new
partners joining the initiative and
bringing their climate esg and
sustainability platforms to google cloud
if you are a google cloud partner with
sustainability solutions and expertise
to share the google cloud ready
sustainability program is open for
applications
learn more about applying for the
program in our blog
we're excited to introduce a
pay-as-you-go pricing model to enable
customers to unlock apogee's api
management capabilities whilst retaining
the flexibility to manage their own
costs
starting today customers will have the
option to use apogee by paying only for
what they are using check out more
details in the blog
cloud wisdom weekly for tech companies
and startups is a new blog series to
answer common questions tech and startup
customers ask
the most recent article discusses five
ways to reduce costs with containers
those are
identify opportunities to reduce cluster
administration
consider serverless to maximize
developer productivity
save with committed use discounts
leverage cost management features
and match workload needs to pricing
models
find out the details of each tip on the
block
data governance includes people
processes and technology which enable
organizations to validate and manage
across dimensions such as data
management protection discoverability
and accountability
for financial data governance
implementations to have trust in their
data and meet regulatory compliance
requirements they must have a solid and
flexible technology pillar from which to
build processes and align people
google cloud can help build that
comprehensive data governance strategy
while allowing you to add third-party
capabilities to meet specific industry
needs
more details on the blog
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link any thoughts or ideas leave
us a comment or tweet us
we'll see you in the cloud
you